In the past week or so, so many people
have been complaining about hitting
their Claude code limit insanely fast.
Claims like one prompt that is about 1%
of the limit is now around 10%. You
could go through X and find tons and
tons of threads about this topic. Even
on a $200 per month plan, people are
reaching the session limit way too fast.
And then we got this post from an
Anthropic employee that basically said
that they are working on a little change
with peak hours and off-peak hours. But
even after that, some people were saying
they were still hitting it really quick
even during off-peak hours. So anyways,
I've been playing around a ton, trying
different doing research, and I have 18
token management hacks for you guys that
I've organized from tier one all the way
up to tier three, so they get more
advanced as we go. I'm very confident
that by the end of this video, you will
feel like your Claude code usage has
doubled, tripled, maybe even five-xed.
So let's not waste any time and just get
straight into the video. So as I've been
optimizing my own token management, I
think that what's really important to
realize first is how tokens actually
work. Because once you realize how
Claude uses tokens, it makes it very
clear how you should actually reverse
engineer the way that you work in order
to use less tokens. So a token is the
smallest unit of text that an AI model
reads and charges you for. It's roughly
one token is one word, but that's not
explicitly true, kind of just a good
baseline. So every time that you send a
message, Claude rereads the entire
conversation from the beginning, and all
of those are tokens that it's charging
you for. So message one, it will read
it, then it will read its reply, and
then message two, and then the reply,
all the way up to your latest prompt.
And it does that every single time. And
I think that alone is a huge lightbulb
moment for a lot of people. This means
as you're having a conversation with
Claude, your cost is compounding, not
just adding. It's exponentially growing.
Meaning message one might cost 500
tokens, message 30 costs 15,000 because
it's rereading everything before it. One
developer actually tracked a 100-plus
message chat and found that 98.5% of all
the tokens were just spent rereading the
old chat history in the session. Like
that's a huge waste. Now yes, the
argument has to be made that well, it
needs the context and it needs to
understand what we're doing, but still,
98.5% is crazy. So take a quick look at
this graphic here. Along the x-axis, we
have message number, and as it
increases, you can see that we have our
per message cost and our cumulative
tokens increasing, but it's not linear.
It's basically each message is rereading
all of the past ones, and it has to
count that in. So message one could be
500, message 30 could be 15,500, which
is 31 times more. And then after 30
messages, you might already be at almost
a quarter million cumulative tokens. Now
on top of all of your own messages,
Claude will also reload your Claude.md,
your MCP servers, your system prompts,
your skills, your files on every single
turn. And this is invisible overhead,
but it is constantly dripping into your
context and your tokens. And a really
important thing to realize is that
bloated context doesn't just cost you
more money, but it also produces worse
output. So you're paying more and you're
getting less. There's this phenomenon
called lost in the middle, which
basically says that models are paying
the most attention in the beginning of
your session and kind of at the end. So
all that stuff in the middle of your
session, kind of in this dip, is getting
ignored. All right. So now that we kind
of understand a little bit more about
how Claude code works and how tokens
work, let's move into the hacks. We're
going to start here with tier one hacks.
These are the ones that are going to be
super easy to implement and everyone
should be able to understand. So we've
got nine of these. Number one is to
start fresh conversations. Use
clear between unrelated tasks. Don't
carry context about topic A into a
conversation about topic B.
So every single message in a long chat
is exponentially more expensive than the
same message in a fresh chat. So this
one habit is the number one thing that
extends your session life, and it's
pretty obvious based on what we just
talked about, so that's why this was
number one.
Okay, number two is to disconnect MCP
servers. Every single connected MCP
server loads all of its tool definitions
into your context on every message. This
is another source of completely
invisible tokens that might just be
eating up and eating away. So one server
alone might be something like 18,000
tokens per message. So run MCP at the
start of each session and disconnect the
ones that you don't need. And better
yet, if you're able to find CLIs for
something, so for example, rather than
having the Google Workspace or Google
Calendar MCP server, which eats a lot of
tokens, just use the Google Workspace
CLI. It's faster, it's cheaper, and I
think the future is moving towards
having our agents use CLIs rather than
MCPs. All right, number three, batch
prompts into one message. Three separate
messages cost three times what one
combined message costs because of the
way that tokens work, right? Instead of
summarize this as one message and then
now extract the issues, now suggest a
fix, send it all in one prompt. If
Claude gets something slightly wrong,
edit your original message and
regenerate instead of sending a full
follow-up correction. Follow-ups stack
onto history permanently, while edits
replace the bad exchange entirely. Now I
will say, there is an argument to be
made here that potentially doing it this
way where you're doing task one, task
two, then task three, might actually be
better output quality. I think it
depends on the actual use case.
Basically, the idea would be if you can
give AI one specific task at a time,
it's going to be better because it's
more specialized and it's more focused.
But this is definitely something that
you should be aware of. Okay, number
four is to use plan mode before any real
task. This lets Claude map out the
approach, ask you the right questions,
and it prevents the single biggest
source of token waste, which is just
having Claude go down the wrong path,
writing code, and then basically
everything that it just did, you have to
basically like scrap and redo. It's just
a huge waste of time and tokens. So you
can add something like this to your
Claude.md. Do not make any changes until
you have 95% confidence in what you need
to build. Ask me follow-up questions
until you reach that confidence level.
This is something that I'm putting into
all of my Claude.mds when I am having it
help me build things. Number five, we
have run  context and
cost.  context shows you exactly
what's eating your tokens right now. So
your conversation history, your MCP
overhead, loaded files, stuff like that.
And  cost shows your actual token
usage and estimated spend for that
current session.
Most people have no idea where their
tokens are going, and these two commands
make the invisible visible. Because if
you don't actually know that you're
bleeding because of MCPs, then how would
you be able to fix that? So when you run
context, this is what it will
look like. It'll basically give you a
screenshot of how many tokens you're at,
what is the cap, and it will estimate
based on the different categories. And
what I did here is this was ran in a
completely fresh session, no chats. So
what that tells me is, okay, before I
even talk to Claude, I'm already down
51,000 tokens because of things like the
system prompt, the system tools, my
custom agents, my skills, memory files,
and here I've actually cleared out all
the MCPs, so there wasn't anything in
there, but those can, like I said,
completely bloat up your tokens right
from the get-go. Okay, number six is to
set up a status line. This kind of goes
hand in hand with having more
visibility. You only actually see this
in your terminal though, so you will
have to do it there. Um and it basically
lets you see what's going on. So right
here you can see in my terminal, I've
got this set up so that I can see the
model I'm using. I can see a visual kind
of progress bar of my usage, and then I
can see
uh 5% of my whole 1 million context
window, and I can see 52,000 tokens out
of 1,000,000, which is a million. And
just to clarify, this isn't my session,
like my five-hour session. This is
basically just indicating that I'm 5% of
the way or 52K out of 1,000K. So all you
have to do is in Claude code in the
terminal, do  status line, and
explain that you want to replicate this
setup. Number seven is just super
simple, but keep your dashboard open.
Same thing with visibility. You might
run into issues with your limit and just
get hit out of nowhere. But if you have
it pulled up next to you or you have it
ready so that you can switch into that
tab and you know, check every 20-40
minutes, then you're going to be able to
pace yourself a little bit better. You
could even set up a automation to
basically check in on it every 30
minutes and send you like a text or a
Slack message to say, "Hey, by the way,
you're getting near your usage." All
right, so number eight, we have be smart
with pasting. Before you drop a document
or a file or something large, just ask
yourself, "Does Claude need to read this
whole thing?" Sometimes it does,
sometimes it needs that full context,
but sometimes it just needs one section
or one page. So if the bug is in one
function, then paste just that function.
Or if it just needs the context of one
little paragraph, just paste that.
Claude needs to be precise about what it
reads, but you also need to be precise
about what you feed it. And number nine,
our last tier one hack, is to actually
watch Claude code work. Don't just fire
off a prompt and walk away or switch
tabs. Watch what Claude is doing,
especially on longer tasks. And this is
because if you actually sit and watch
it, sometimes you'll realize it's going
down the wrong path. Sometimes it gets
stuck in its own loops, rereads the same
files, things like that. So if it's
doing that, you might as well just stop
it right there. Kind of the same idea as
plan mode. Why would you let it go down
the wrong path, waste all your tokens,
and then just have to scrap it all? In a
bad loop, 80% of the tokens are being
used producing zero value. So if you're
able to just watch your session run
until you know it's going down the right
path, it could save you thousands of
tokens. All right, let's kick it up a
little bit. Let's move into our tier two
hacks, and for these ones we have five
of them. So number one is to keep your
Claude.md file lean. Place it in your
project root, whether that is globally
or in in local projects. Claude auto
reads it at the start of every single
chat as system context. So keep it under
200 lines. Include things like your tech
stack, your coding conventions, your
build commands, the 95% confidence rule,
only the most important things, and you
need to treat this like an index. Route
to where more data lives. And it's a
complete mindset shift. This file
basically just tells Claude code, "Where
is everything that it needs and what to
do every single time?" So it can point
to files that are huge, but that way it
just is, "Okay, I don't need this right
now, but if I do need this, I know
exactly where to look." And because it
knows exactly where to look, it's not
going to waste time or tokens searching
through and reading other files. It's
just able to grab it right there by the
file name. And the reason I say this is
a mindset shift because you should be
doing this with other things, not just
your Claude.md, with your skills or with
your you know, master reference guide
sheets. I saw someone talking about how
they created an index that's super super
lean, and it shows Claude code exactly
where to go in the Claude code
documentation. So if it needs help with
something related to Claude code, it
doesn't have to search through the whole
database, it can just say, "Okay, here's
my index file. I know exactly which URL
to look up at." Super simple. You want
to keep this lean and trim it all the
time. It's always a work in progress
because every single chat, not just like
your session, every single message
Claude.md gets read. So, if your
Claude.md file is 1,000 lines, every
single time you shoot off a message,
even if you just say hi,
the whole thing's going to get read.
Okay, number two here is to be surgical
with file references. Don't just say
something like, "Here's my whole repo,
go find the bug." Say something more
like, "Check the verify user function
inside the off.js file." Or you can also
use @filename to point at specific files
instead of once again letting Claude
explore freely. The whole idea of being
specific and routing. All right, so
number three, I'm saying to compact at
around 60% capacity. Auto compact
triggers at like 95% by which point your
context is already pretty degraded. So,
run/context to check your capacity
percentage or you should have the status
line set up and at about 60% just run
the /compact with specific instructions
on what it should actually be
preserving. After three to four compacts
in a row, the quality does start to
degrade. So, at that point, once you've
done three or four, just get a session
summary, /clear, give the session
summary back, and then keep going. All
right, so number four, short breaks are
actually costing you. Claude code uses
prompt training to avoid reprocessing
unchanged context, but the cache has a
5-minute timeout. So, if you step away
and you come back and it's been longer
than 5 minutes, your next message
reprocesses everything from scratch at
full cost. And that is why some people
feel like their usage just randomly
spikes if they might have, you know,
stepped away and came back. So, if
you're going to do that, just consider
doing a /compact or a /clear before you
step away. All right, number five,
command output bloat. When Claude runs
shell commands, the full output enters
your context window. So, if you have a
command then it comes back with 200
commits or, you know, just tons and tons
of data, then all of that is tokens that
get sent to your model. So, really the
takeaway here is to be intentional about
what you let Claude run. If you know in
a certain project that it doesn't need
to use certain commands, then you can go
ahead and in that project deny those
permissions. And this is another one
that seems like it's invisible because
when it runs like a bash or, you know,
certain commands, it basically just has
like one line and you don't actually see
all of the tokens that it has, you know,
sent there. All right, so sitting here
editing this video and there's just one
more thing that I wanted to get off my
chest and it's basically about hitting
your limit. And, you know, the goal of
this video and your goal should be to
optimize so that you don't hit your
limit, but I don't think that you should
associate hitting your limit with like
it shouldn't be a negative connotation
because ultimately if you're doing a lot
of these hacks and you are not just like
being wasteful with tokens, then hitting
your limit is actually a good thing if
you think about it because it means that
you are using this tool so much and I
think that's what you want to be. I
think you want to be a power user of
this tool to the point where it's like
got to wait again. And, you know,
waiting sucks, but
people that are using it so much are
going to be so much more productive and
so much farther ahead than people who
are never hitting their limits, you
know, not make not getting their their
money's worth and not truly
getting the leverage that you are now
getting. So, anyways, quick little raw
rant there, but I think it's an
important mindset shift to have, you
know?
Just something to think about. All
right, so we're moving on to tier three
now. I hope you guys feel like you
already have a lot of things that you
want to implement and these ones are
getting a little crazier as well. So,
we've got four of these here and I've
got a few bonus ones also, but number
one is to pick the right model. So,
Sonnet for your default most coding
work, Haiku for sub-agents, formatting,
simple tasks, Opus for deep
architectural planning and only when
Sonnet wasn't enough. Try to keep this
under 20% of usage or unless you just
really, really need it for that project.
Now, a little tip here is when you have
a huge code base and you want to do
certain things like maybe a review, then
try bringing in Codex. There is an
official plugin now and I made a video
about this. I'll tag that right up here,
but you could basically have, you know,
Opus and Sonnet working together to
build you, you know, a project or a code
base and then you could just bring in
Codex to actually review everything. And
that way you're saving yourself on the
Claude tokens. The next one, number two
here, is the cost of sub-agents. Agent
workflows use roughly seven to 10 times
more tokens than a standard single agent
session. Now, why is that? Because they
wake up with their own full context and
it's a separate instance. So, they
basically have to reload everything when
you start up the new session. All of
those files, all of the system tools,
like everything like that. Now, what you
can do though, which is helpful, is to
delegate to sub-agents for one-off
tasks, especially if you want that
one-off task to use Haiku. So, maybe you
need to process a lot of information or
maybe you need to do a ton of research
and get just like a summary back. Now,
yes, tokens are still tokens no matter
what at the end of the day, but if you
can make 80% of your tokens a cheaper
model rather than 80% of your tokens an
expensive model, then you're going to be
saving money.
And then, of course, agent teams are
cool. Um sometimes I really do actually
like them and it helps me get more
higher quality outputs, but they're
very, very expensive. So,
try to use them very sparingly. All
right, so number three is to understand
peak hours. So, we just talked about at
the beginning how they've adjusted how
fast your 5-hour session window drains
based on demand during the peak hours,
which are 8:00 a.m. to 2:00 p.m. Eastern
Time on weekdays.
But off-peak, this is when your usage is
kind of either normal or it lasts a
little longer and these are afternoons,
evenings, weekends. So, if you actually
think about this strategically, maybe
you want to make sure that you're
running big refactors or multi-agent
sessions or big projects during off-peak
hours only. Otherwise, you're going to,
you know, drain right through that peak
session. And on top of this, we'll call
this a little hack 3.5, which is the one
I kind of alluded to earlier when I
said, "Hey, just keep open your Claude
account so you can see your usage at all
times." If you're near a reset and you
have room left in your allocation, then
go heavy. Try to hit that usage limit
before it resets. Get your money's
worth. Let your agents go loose at that
point. And on the other side, if you're
getting near your limit, but you still
have lots of time, then step away. This
is your time to take a break, take a
walk, make some lunch, come back with a
full budget instead of burning the last
5% on something small and getting stuck
mid-task and having to just kind of, you
know, lose that flow state that you
might have been in. Okay, number four,
your system's constitution,
which is Claude.md. This should contain
stable decisions, architecture rules,
and progress summaries. Think of it like
the source of truth that makes every
prompt shorter and shorter. Save
decisions, not conversations. Every
architectural call that you store there
is a paragraph that you never have to
type again. So, this builds on top of
the way that you were thinking about it
back in tier one. You can add rules in
there that basically tell it, "Hey, I
want you to help me make sure I'm being
smart about tokens. Use sub-agents for
any exploration or research. If a task
needs three plus files or multi-file
analysis, spawn a sub-agent and only
return summarized insights. Spawn that
sub-agent in Haiku." And here's a little
prompt that I have at the bottom of my
Claude.md and I will say before I read
this out, you have to be careful because
when you make a file like this, um kind
of self-learning or self-evolving, you
have to check on it frequently because
you don't want it to accidentally get
too bloated. But here I said, "Applied
learning. When something fails
repeatedly, when Nate has to re-explain
or when a workaround is found for a
platform tool or limitation, add a
one-line bullet here. Keep each bullet
under 15 words, no explanations. Only
add things that will save time in future
sessions." And then it's got some
bullets. Now, I'm not saying this is the
most optimal prompt, but I think this
sort of system of having your Claude.md
actually learn and continuously think
about how it can save you time and
tokens is a good idea to play with. All
right, so I know that we just went
through a ton of stuff. This whole slide
deck will be available for download for
free in my free school community. The
link for that will be down in the
description. But right now, what you
should go do are these things. Go
run/context. See what it looks like. Go
to some of your active sessions,
run/cost. Status line, make sure it's
showing your model, your context
percentage, and your token count. Make
sure you pull up your Claude usage
dashboard so you can see your remaining
allocation and what time it resets.
Disconnect unused MCP servers. Start
complex tasks in plan mode. Use /clear
when you're switching to an unrelated
task. Manually compact at 60% context.
Batch your multi-step instructions into
single messages and schedule heavy
sessions for off-peak hours and really
just be mindful about the actual timing.
So, I wanted to kind of leave you guys
with one, maybe two messages. The first
thing is just the idea that there is a
balance between quality and cost. And
so, that's kind of a game that you have
to play a little bit and sometimes you
do have to go for the higher quality,
which ultimately is going to cost you
more money and that's just the way it
works. But the other thing is just to
keep it simple and think about what we
talked about at the beginning of this
video, how tokens actually work, how
Claude code actually charges you. Most
people don't need a bigger plan, they
need to stop resending their entire
conversation history 30 times when you
could just send it, you know, five
times. It's not a limits problem, it's a
context hygiene problem. But anyways,
that is going to do it for this one. If
you guys enjoyed or you learned
something new, please give it a like, it
helps me out a ton. And as always, I
appreciate you guys making it to the end
of the video. I'll see you all in the
next one.
Thanks, everyone.